Speaker 1: Our friends over at The Good
Liars, they're really good at this stuff.
They talk to people at different political
events. They go to anti-vaccine events. They
go to Trump rallies, they go to all sorts of
different things. They were able to find and
how hard they had to look, I don't really know.
It was probably pretty easy at these events.
They found a woman who believes that Joe Biden is
currently being played by actors. In other words,
they're sort of, I guess, body doubles in
makeup. I don't know. And one of the actors that
this woman believes is playing Joe Biden, is the
great comedic actor, Jim Carrey. Let's play it and
then we're going to talk about it. And I know
that this is funny in some ways, but this is
actually really scary. And we'll we'll talk about
that. You think Biden is not alive right now?
Speaker 4: Now, the guy that's doing the standup
job of trying to wake people up. Is an actor
wearing a mask. I mean, there's several
different people playing Joe Biden at this point.
And then when when he fell up
the stairs going on the airplane,
I myself think that that was Jim Carrey.
Speaker 1: Now, why would it be Jim
Carrey? I don't know. I would love
to get an explanation about that.
Speaker 4: I've heard that he was one of them.
Speaker 3: I wait, wait, wait, wait. You think
that Jim Carrey was wearing a mask, right?
Speaker 1: And was the acting president.
Speaker 4: And being silly by following
up the stairs three different times?
And James Woods also, I think, is one
of the doppelganger mask wearing people.
Speaker 1: Now, isn't James? I don't want
to say this incorrectly, but I thought James
Woods was a Republican. Why would he be a.
James Woods has praised Trump. I don't know
why James Woods would be willing to be part of
this subterfuge. So, listen, I'm going to take
this seriously. I'm going to take this seriously.
I don't want to joke about this. It can be really
hard to figure out a diagnosis for folks like
this. I spoke to some psychiatrists about this.
When we see someone like this and we say, okay,
is this is this like what is happening here? We
try to make sense of how someone could end up
believing stuff like this. One possibility is
what's called delusional disorder. You're
delusional. It's a type of psychosis where
a person can't tell what is real and what's
imagined. So as real as this microphone is for me,
the person sees as just, just as real that Jim
Carrey and James Woods are playing the role of
Biden, who has died. And the main feature of
delusional disorder is the presence of delusions
which are truly unshakable beliefs that something
is true. And people with delusional disorder often
can continue to socialize, seemingly. Normally,
you could go and have lunch with this woman and
talk about the weather and whatever, and it's the
subject of their delusion where it's just wacky.
But their other behavior is not obviously odd or
bizarre. Like, they're not all collecting feces
at home, you know, or whatever. Like, they just
they live normally, but they have these specific,
unshakable, delusional beliefs. Now, delusional
disorder by itself is actually pretty rarely
diagnosed. It typically occurs in middle age or
later, and the causes can be genetic, biological,
environmental. Now, that would point to why people
who have one set of delusional beliefs that they
often hold strange beliefs about a few things,
but again, they typically function normally. Now,
the other day we mentioned a different but similar
condition. It's called paraphrasing a disorder.
So it might sound like schizophrenia. It's not.
It's something different. Paraphrasing here is
a mental disorder characterized by a very
organized system of paranoid delusions.
They don't have to have hallucinations. And
that typically onset is later in life. 60 plus
and paraphrasing doesn't have its own section
in the DSM five, because often when someone
presents with, paraphrase, Enya, they end up
being diagnosed with delusional disorder. So
these these are very blurry lines and
they can be hard to sort of diagnose.
This is more common in women. Now, let's take it a
step further. Again, we're taking this seriously,
saying, do these people just need to be convinced
or do they need medication? We're trying to really
think it through in a serious matter. There
is a study that opens the door even wider. The
study is called Belief in Conspiracy Theories The
Predictive Role of Schizo Type Machiavellianism
and Primary Psychopathy. What this study looks
at is whether it's a type B, Machiavellianism
grandiose narcissism, vulnerable narcissism,
primary psychopathy and secondary psychopathy
are good predictors of how likely someone
is to believe conspiracy theories. Now, this
correlation wouldn't necessarily say to us, Well,
if you have someone with a specific delusional
conspiracy theory like this woman, it doesn't
guarantee that they are psychopaths or they are
schizophrenic or whatever the case may be,
but it might have some kind of predictive role
about how likely are those folks to end up
believing some of these things. And then you
could kind of work backwards and try to figure
out, is there medication that will help? This
is really serious stuff. The psychiatrist I've
spoken to, my dad is a psychiatrist, have said
sometimes medications can help folks like
this. But it is not super typical that
if you give someone who's quite ill with these
types of beliefs a pill that four weeks later
or eight weeks later, they no longer believe any
of this stuff, the paranoia or the delusion might
be less intrusive. They might be less focused
on it, it might form less of a sort of obsessive
nature for them. They might not be at the Trump
rallies talking to people, but this is still a not
completely well understood area of mental
health. Now, what do we know for sure?
There's too much stigma around mental
health treatment in the United States.
We have a lot of undiagnosed mental
illness in the United States,
and we have a lot of we have not nearly enough
access to mental health treatment. And that's part
partially a stigma thing. It's. Partially a health
care system thing. And this is really a big deal,
but this goes well beyond politics. And I think
that that's the important thing to understand.